[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen an meiner seite ist norbert
lehmann mit allen wichtigen zusätzlich
gutendorf familie und das sind die
wichtigsten nachrichten themen von heute
5 - 1 in kiew die präsidenten polens und
des baltikums sind bei selensky
willkommen der bundespräsident nicht ein
diplomatischer schaden haufen mit dem
rücken gegen
den benzinpreisschock und für die umwelt
wie das neun euro ticket für bus und
bahn funktioniert und wie man es bekommt
und die bayern am boden wieder
ausgeschieden im viertelfinale der
champions league gegen den großen
außenseiter villarreal aus spanien
dass die ukraine einen besuch des
bundespräsidenten ablehnen stößt
hierzulande auf ziemlichen unmut das sei
extrem ärgerlich irritierend ein
diplomatischer affront unklar ist wie
genau die absage dem bundespräsidialamt
übermittelt wurde in kiew empfing
präsident selensky heute jedenfalls nur
die staatschefs von polen estland
lettland und litauen und eben nicht den
bundespräsidenten der eigentlich auch
dabei sein sollte er reiste gestern nach
berlin zurück lars boom hat berichtet
als frank walter steinmeier gestern den
rückflug von warschau nach berlin
antritt zieht seine ausladung bereits
politisch weite kreise in einem
hörfunkinterview macht der bundeskanzler
deutlich dass er regelmäßig mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten telefoniert und
die absage an den bundespräsidenten für
nicht nachvollziehbar hält
der bundespräsident
wäre gerne in die ukraine gefahren und
hätte den präsidenten besucht das ist
das staatsoberhaupt der bundesrepublik
deutschland übrigens gerade
wiedergewählt wegen seiner verdienste
und seiner leistung mit einer großen
weit über alle parteigrenzen hinweg
reichenden mehrheit und deshalb wäre es
auch gut gewesen ihn zu empfangen es ist
jedem prinz etwas irritierend um es
höflich zu sagen alle regierungsparteien
stellen sich auf die seite des
bundespräsidenten allen mehr oder
weniger offen die ausladung 1 in
afrika ihnen muss auch begreifen dass
bei aller
nach sich die man irgendwann das
tatsächlich für die uns in deutschland
eine frau ist und sie eine reise von
scheuch ist schwer zu sagen und ich
erleichtert die linke macht darauf
aufmerksam dass deutschland
viertgrösster waffenlieferant und
größter geldgeber der ukraine sei ich
finde das zutiefst problematisch jeden
tag aus kiel forderung zu stellen und
dann das deutsche staatsoberhaupt nicht
zu empfangen ist auch angesichts des
brutalen krieges von putins so nicht zu
akzeptieren meines erachtens cdu-chef
merz kritisiert die käfer entscheidung
zeigt aber zugleich auch verständnis
offensichtlich sitzen die vorbehalte
gegen die russlandpolitik der spd in
vielen osteuropäischen ländern sehr tief
und das wiederum kann ich gut verstehen
damit ist der außenpolitische klar auch
in der deutschen innenpolitik angekommen
fragen wir nach in der ukraine bei tim
krüger in kiew gibt es denn heute
erklärungen für die ausladung des
bundespräsidenten
also wir haben den kontakt zum umfeld
des präsidenten gesucht aber es gibt
noch keine offizielle erklärung zu
dieser ablehnenden haltung zu den
umständen dieser ablehnenden haltung zum
steinmeier besuch aber wie dem auch
immer sei diese ganze diskussion über
diesen besuch kommt zu einem denkbar
schlechten zeitpunkt denn das verhältnis
beider länder vor allem das verhältnis
der ukraine zu deutschland während
dieses krieges war ja nicht das beste
und es gab durchaus eine positive
entwicklung und zwar am vergangenen
sonntag als bundeskanzler scholz mit dem
präsidenten sie lenski telefoniert hat
und danach sagte zielinski dass er
durchaus eine positive änderung in der
haltung der bundesrepublik in bezug auf
die unterstützung der ukraine
festgestellt habe klar ist dass der
ukrainischen regierung einen besuch des
bundeskanzlers wesentlich wichtiger
gewesen wäre denn dann hätte man hier in
kiew wirklich über handfestes verhandeln
können nämlich über die lieferung von
schweren waffen die die ukraine so
dringend braucht für die bevorstehende
oder wahrscheinlich bevorstehende
großoffensive der zwischen streitkräfte
im osten und im südosten des landes
dankeschön nach kräftiger
us präsident biden hat russland erstmals
völkermord vorgeworfen die beweise dafür
häuften sich der kreml hält diese
wertung für inakzeptabel und verstärkt
seine angriffe im osten der ukraine in
mario pohl warten nach angaben des
bürgermeisters mehr als 100.000 menschen
darauf dass sie die belagerte stadt
verlassen können weite teile sind
zerstört und offenbar unter russische
kontrolle
alexandra vacano
sie hätten ihre waffen freiwillig
niedergelegt sich ergeben und in
kriegsgefangenschaft begeben mehr als
1000 ukrainische soldaten in mariupol
meldet das russische
verteidigungsministerium
und diese bilder aus dem russischen
fernsehen sollen das belegen
mario pohl wichtige hafenstadt und
industriestandort seit kriegsbeginn
belagert von der russischen armee und
umkämpft bis heute hier werden russische
einheiten bei ihren vorbereitungen für
den weiteren kampf gezeigt dass hier nun
so viele ukrainische soldaten aufgegeben
hätten dazu kein kommentar ihrer armee
aber sie kämpften unter bomben um jeden
meter der stadt heißt es und
der feind unternimmt eine offensive in
der nähe des stahlwerks of style und des
seehafens in südlicher region versucht
der feind einzelne siedlungen
einzunehmen jedoch ohne erfolg
auch aktiv im osten ist der neue ziel
der russischen angriffe teile der stadt
in flammen nach artilleriebeschuss dann
noch dies explosionen möglicherweise von
international geächteten streubomben in
hf das soll dieses video zeigen
tatsächlich unternimmt der feind
erbärmliche versuche unsere friedlichen
bewohner zu terrorisieren
indem ihnen in die stadtrat geführt die
minen detonieren nicht sofort ich bitte
alle einwohner von hp über vorsichtig zu
sein
die russische armee sie verlegt immer
mehr truppen in die ost ukraine
das sollen diese satellitenbilder zeigen
offenbar steht hier eine großoffensive
bevor
deshalb wollen viele von hier fliehen
oder versuchten es aber die flucht
korridore waren heute geschlossen die
waffenruhe wurde nicht eingehalten
der überfall russlands auf die ukraine
führt gerade in finnland und schweden zu
einem meinungswandel beide bislang
neutralen länder denken laut über einen
nato beitritt nach noch ist in der
region nur norwegen in den westlichen
verteidigungsbündnis käme finnland dazu
dann würde sich die direkte grenze
zwischen russland und der nato gebiet
mit
1300 kilometer mehr auf einen schlag
verdoppeln bei schweden steht vor allem
die strategisch wichtige insel gotland
im blickpunkt heike kruse berichtet
seit wochen zeigt die schwedische armee
präsenz wie hier auf der ostseeinsel
gotland eine warnung an russland soll
das sein und schweden fast eine
nato-mitgliedschaft immer mehr ins auge
heute kam die finnische
ministerpräsidentin nach stockholm denn
beide regierungen diskutieren die selbe
frage nato-beitritt ja oder nein
wir müssen das wirklich herausfinden was
ist das beste für schweben und für
unsere sicherheit und unseren frieden in
dieser neuen situation natürlich ist es
für uns wichtig die aktuelle diskussion
zu verfolgen deshalb sind wir in einem
sehr engen austausch
um 700 millionen euro hat nachbar
finnland gerade seinen
verteidigungshaushalt erhöht
es gibt verschiedene sichtweisen den
nato-beitritt beantragen oder nicht wir
müssen das alles sehr gründlich
analysieren sowie das magdalena gesagt
hat wir werden diese diskussion in den
kommenden wochen im parlament führen mix
das finnische parlament erhielt heute
einen bericht der regierung als
diskussionsgrundlage eine art für und
wider nato beitritt ohne konkrete
empfehlung laut umfragen sind inzwischen
70 prozent finden für die
nato-mitgliedschaft anfang des jahres
waren es gerade 30 prozent seiner
sicherheit sollte findet nun doch der
nato beitreten
still dafür trotz risiken aber der
ukraine krieg zeigt dass man russland
nicht trauen kann
die große befürchtung der beitritt
gegner russland könnte cyber angriffe
starten oder sogar grenzkonflikte
provozieren eine schwierige entscheidung
aber finnland und schweden wollen sie
noch in diesem frühjahr fällen
wie geht's weiter mit den
bundeswehreinsätzen in mali das hat
außenministerin baerbock gestern mit den
soldaten besprochen heute traf sie auf
staatschef dollar denen das militär vor
einem jahr an die macht putschte
sehrbrock forderte wahlen und ein klares
bekenntnis zur demokratie
außerdem sagte sie solange mali eng mit
russischen akteuren zusammen arbeite
könne deutschland nicht weiter malische
streitkräfte ausbilden
eine rentenerhöhung wie seit jahrzehnten
nicht mehr hat das bundeskabinett auf
den weg gebracht ab ersten juli geht es
im osten um mehr als 6 prozent hoch im
westen um über fünf prozent
allerdings fürchten wohlfahrtsverbände
dass die inflation das meiste auffrisst
auch die erwerbsminderungsrente soll
wieder angehoben werden
2024 um bis zu 75 prozent
sie geht an menschen die aus
gesundheitlichen gründen nicht mehr
arbeiten können
außerdem sollen ja alle finanziell
entlastet werden die unter den hohen
tank preisen leiden und zwar ab juni für
drei monate zum einen sind solange die
energie steuer auf sprit dadurch könnte
ein liter benzin 30 cent günstiger
werden ein liter diesel 14 cent zum
anderen soll es ein billig ticket für
den nahverkehr geben 90 tage lang für
neun euro pro monat wie das funktioniert
und wo es noch hakt zeigt romanesco war
drei monate lang im bus und bahn zum
sondertarif dass neun euro ticket soll
kommen interessierte können es bald am
schalter online oder am automaten kaufen
heißt es deutschlandweit soll es gelten
allerdings nur in regionalen
verkehrsmitteln die anbieter rechnen mit
mehr fahrgästen bei gleichem angebot wir
werden volle busse und bahnen in
deutschland sehen wir werden auch
überfüllte busse und bahnen in
deutschland sehen es gibt keine
nennenswerten reserven die wir da
nachschieben können wer bereit sein abo
oder semesterticket hat soll anteilig
gutschriften oder erstattungen erhalten
die anbieter versprechen dass
automatisch zu verrechnen
fahrgastverbände befürchten überfüllte
regionalzüge richtung küste in der
ferienzeit zudem kritisieren sie dass
der fernverkehr nicht berücksichtigt
werde
diejenigen die von berlin nach wolfsburg
pendeln mit dem ic die von mannheim das
stuttgart von götting nach hannover von
kiel nach hamburg den fernverkehr nutzen
die haben alle nichts davon und die
schauen in die röhre und das ist
ungerecht wegen der gestiegenen
energiekosten ist das nur ein euro
ticket als finanzielle entlastung
gedacht umweltverbände hoffen dass
autofahrer wegen der attraktiven preise
auf bus und bahn umsteigen um sie zu
halten fordern mobilitäts forscher
anreize über die drei monate hinaus und
darf nicht mehr ganze abos anbieten
sondern man muss teil leistung anbieten
flexiblere angebote machen so dass
menschen die im home-office sehen auch
kein abo kaufen müssen und dennoch beim
öpnv bleiben ab 11 juni soll das 9 euro
ticket gelten von verbandsseite heißt es
dass es das angebot auch für nur ein
oder zwei monate geben soll
und auch heute der blick auf die korona
zahlen die sieben tage inzidenz geht
weiter zurück auf jetzt 1000
44,7 das robert-koch-institut hat
176 1303 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden gemeldet 38
1682 weniger als vergangenen mittwoch
361 todesfälle kamen dazu
chinas an ticona strategie ist radikal
und rücksichtslos der nicht enden
wollende lockdown in shanghai stürzt
viele der 26 millionen einwohner in
existenznot eingesperrt in der eigenen
wohnung haben nicht alle genug zu essen
es fehlt an medizin und die zahl der
neuinfektionen in chinas größter stadt
steigt mehr als 26.000 ansteckungen
melden die behörden heute ein neuer
höchststand ulf röller berichtet
nur blühende landschaften zeigt das
chinesische staatsfernsehen
mittendrin presse den ski von corona
krise ist in diesen bildern keine spur
shanghai dagegen meidet der präsident
die millionenmetropole ist seit wochen
im ausnahmezustand
im netz macht sich frust breit die
menschen protestieren für ein ende der
quarantäne schreien um hilfe
unter shanghais stillstand leiden nicht
nur die bürger sondern auch die
wirtschaft panahi ist seit mehr als zwei
wochen in quarantäne
er musste wie die meisten sein geschäft
schließen
oder dass alle
die wirtschaftliche schaden ist
gleichzusetzen mit ein
ich sag mal so regel alle krieg
der lock down in shanghai bremste auch
den frachtverkehr im größten hafen der
welt die globalen lieferketten und damit
die weltwirtschaft droht schaden zu
nehmen china ist eine exportweltmeister
und das zeigt natürlich daran dass zb
ist 30 prozent aller produkte weltweit
irgendein kleines teilchen von china
drin habe und deswegen wenn china eine
in einen stoff bekommt dann haben der
unter umständen weltweit irgendwann die
krippe es gibt hoffnung der locker und
in shanghai wird langsam gelockert die
ersten dürfen wieder ihre wohnung
verlassen
nach den schüssen in der new yorker u
bahn station wird jetzt nach einem
62-jährigen als möglichen täter
gefahndet der verdächtige soll einen
kleinlaster gemietet haben dessen
schlüssel am tatort gefunden wurde bei
der u bahn attacke waren gestern 23
menschen verletzt worden der täter hatte
rauchbomben gezündet und auf passagiere
geschossen hinweise auf einen
terroristischen hintergrund hat die
polizei nicht
ungewöhnlich heftiger starkregen hat in
südafrika überschwemmungen und
erdrutsche ausgelöst
259 tote wurden bislang geborgen
zahlreiche menschen werden noch vermisst
betroffen ist die provinz kwazulu natal
im osten des landes mit der
hafenmetropole dörte mehr von sandra
preis
drücken
straßen häuser einfach weggespült
durban/südafrika
heftiger starkregen hat in und rund um
die hafenstadt massive überschwemmungen
und erdrutsche ausgelöst
hunderte menschen kamen ums leben die
steine kam von dort oben sie haben mein
haus zerstört wir haben versucht
davonzulaufen mit den kindern mein
kleiner sohn er wurde von der erde
verschüttet
wir hatten glück wir haben ihnen da
herausgeholt wir haben ihn gefunden
tausende häuser und hütten wurden laut
behörden zerstört oder beschädigt viele
straßen sind unpassierbar
das erschwert die rettungsarbeiten
präsident rammer poster besuchte gegen
mittag die region und versprach hilfe
wir
werden auch andere orte besuchen die von
den überschwemmungen betroffen sind
damit wir wissen wie groß die schäden
sind und welche hilfe nötig ist
mittlerweile wurde das militär
mobilisiert mit welcher kraft das wasser
wütete lässt sich anhand dieser bilder
erahnen zahlreiche menschen werden noch
vermisst und in den nächsten tagen soll
es weiter regnen
hatte schnitt jetzt zur champions league
die hatten sich die bayern anders
vorgestellt nur 1 1 zu 1 gestern abend
gegen den underdog villarreal der das
hinspiel gewonnen hatte nach dem frühen
aus im dfb pokal scheiterte ehrgeizige
fcb jetzt auch noch im viertelfinale in
der königsklasse eine saison fast zum
abhaken die 88 minuten mit blick auf
bayern trainer nagelsmann ein schneller
konter der spanier die einzige
nachlässigkeit hart bestraft durch den
ausgleich der außenseiter statt der
bayern im halbfinale der hauptgrund
liegt laut nagelsmann bei eine woche
zurück im spiel aber das duell verloren
da war nicht gut gespielt heute
52 minuten lang ein cs anrennen gegen
einen abwehrstarken gegner dann endlich
lewandowskis platzierter schuss zum 1 0
müller vergibt eine der seltenen
großchancen eine verlängerung deutet
sich an doch dann dieser shop moment
vorm tor müssen wir vielleicht mehr
machen aber ein gegentor lager auf
keinen fall in der luft bitter für die
bayern das viertelfinale aus kostet
millionen an prämien und macht ihre
saison bilanz immer enttäuschender
unternehmer fußballkrimi die zweite
partie gestern abend real gegen chelsea
die madrilenen trotz der niederlage
weiter dank ihres ausnahmestürmers karim
benzema er lässt real madrid weiter
träumen mit seinem tor zum 2 3 in der
verlängerung traf karim benzema direkt
ins herz des fc chelsea wir hatten es
verdient weiterzukommen aber uns fehlte
heute das glück dabei wird chelsea nach
einer 3 0-führung auch durch tore der
deutschen antonio rüdiger und timo
werner schon wie der sichere sieger des
duells doch in der 80 minute rettete
rodrigo real madrid in die verlängerung
und dann zauberte stürmer benzema madrid
mit seinem tor ins
champions-league-halbfinale
zwei viertelfinal entscheidungen gestern
zwei gibt es heute abend alles zu sehen
bei uns um 23 uhr im zdf sportstudio
champions league eine der
erfolgreichsten piloten in der bob
geschichte beendet ihre karriere die
zweimalige weltmeisterin variabler ja
man kann ihr größter triumph der
olympiasieg in pyeongchang 2018 dieses
jahr bei den winterspielen in peking
holte sie silber die 31 jährige will nun
ein studium in ihrer heimatstadt bilden
beginnen
dafür wünschen wir natürlich auch viel
erfolg absolut einige von ihnen dürfte
das jetzt ganz besonders interessieren
die gewinnzahlen vom mittwochslotto 27
22 29 42 46 und die superzahl 2 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5
hundert
57 das wetter bringt morgen schauer und
gewitter die details hat gleich aus dem
verlies marietta slomka begrüßt sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute journal
danke für ihr interesse alles gute ihnen
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine front hatte
uns bereits heute erreicht und in der
nach zu überquert sie uns allmählich
südostwärts ja und sie braucht ziemlich
lange dafür auch tagsüber ist sie
unterwegs nach südosten und wird einige
schauer und gewitter auslösen und das
hauptsächlich in den bergen wir schauen
in die nacht regnet es schon quer über
deutschland dahinter lockert es auf
hinter der front und davor ist es noch
relativ ruhig bei tiefsten temperaturen
von 4 bis 7 grad im südosten und elf
grad nach westen hin morgen tagesverlauf
also weiterhin mit schauern und
gewittern die front zieht allmählich
südwärts und dabei werden die gewitter
ausgelöst eben hauptsächlich in den
bergen dahinter gibt es noch viele
wolken aber hier und da zeigt sich schon
die sonne und auch davor zeigt sich noch
die sonne dort bei 22 grad im südosten
deutschlands richtung bayern sonst 12
bis 15 grad an den küsten und die
nächsten tage am karfreitag einige
schauer aber es wird allmählich
trockener und vor allem im nordosten ist
es deutlich kühler als im südwesten bei
8 bis 21 grad und samstag dann vorbei
verbreitet trocken ein schöner abend